[Music]
good morning everyone welcome back to
GameSpot live
I am Ricci I'm here with David what's
going on David it's up guys how you guys
doing we are gonna be playing Witcher 3
with the Henry Cavill mod makes it the
face mod for sure
based on the Netflix show yeah so this
is just the Nexus mod and it is made of
eyeshadow phonics and it's just one that
that puts a face mask on to our girl
here yeah there are more mods including
a sword and some clothes but we wanted
to get the face out there for you guys
today check it out and it's important
one it is it is and it's look it looks
good let's just jump right into it here
you guys can see how this model looks
it's like a big reveal yeah now we
couldn't start with the bathtub and and
that that good beginning there because
you know that wouldn't be nice for
stream but there is and we're gonna
start the game off a fresh fresh start
fresh face yeah you know and just let
you guys know hopefully check and help
us out if you guys know where a barber
is in the early game hope right there is
one somewhere but if we were it's beyond
us we forgot yeah if we get to a barber
I'm gonna we're gonna try to make his
hair like super long to really really
make it match how Henry Cavill looks
yeah he was it like longer in the
showdown most of the time there was
something that I was reading though
earlier about how just cuz like the
Netflix timeline apparently it's got
different timelines and like The Witcher
you know storyline I'm not particularly
familiar with it are I know Jacob Decker
our very own Jacob Decker absolutely
loves this year yep
so hopefully we can we can do his love
of the series some justice but he's got
a scar on his eye which I think doesn't
happen until a particular moment those
of you who are familiar with Witcher
will probably know that they added this
on it looks good have you guys seen the
show let us know and chat I mean most of
you have probably played the game but
have you seen the show yet
I watched episode 1 and I'm gonna get
back into it but it was good you like
that I did
I'm just I'm just looking at the the
texture man you really want to look good
he really does and I keep thinking
Superman but like it's hard not to he
makes a great he makes a great look for
Witcher for sure so let's uh it's
looking good it going let's see what we
can do so this is the definitely the
early point in the game I haven't played
through that is beautiful yeah this game
still hold it's not even that old but
you know just still holds up really well
it's more as visuals mm-hmm everything
really yeah so let's find a key with our
whoops yep
let me crank this up a little bit yeah
Chad if you'd like to show I'm seeing uh
we got Clell Vig saying that he liked to
show it let us know what show was badass
yeah keep it going cuz there I've seen
the whole show there we go I've heard uh
you know I've heard mixed reviews from
it for sure but I know a lot of a lot of
people who really like like the story in
the books more than just you know maybe
the game is right the books I never got
to like at all that's me you talk to you
like hey what's up yeah I'm Henry are
you impressed you could you face me for
a second I'm Henry Cavill what's up kW
in chat it's so funny seeing his face it
is look at that it's vest square job
yeah it's really good
[Music]
you know watching the show
henry cavill voice is really good yeah
just as like grainy and like it you know
you can't replace it is it's very good
and it's comparable to this like I think
they did it justice his character the
whole look overall is good but
specifically the voice is very good so
chat so for someone who like me has
always been kind of interested in
getting into Witcher but never really
got the time let me know what's your
favorite thing about Witcher 3 what do
you think if you were to try to convince
someone to play this game what would be
your selling
yeah sell us we're both we both have
like dipped our toes in Witcher but
hardly so right so share your love for
Witcher 3
tell us what's up a lot of people are
saying the show is very good nice and
Henry is a good girl
guess she prefers practice to theory
there she is training that's a serie
it's good face just says it all we're
talking right through the dialogue my
bad but it's so good yeah low heap says
I prefer Game of Thrones you know fair
enough comparison what do you think
David you know I mean they're both in
this like fantasy genre they are I do
want to finish this which are Netflix to
make the full comparison by the way from
like a show ya know heap says uh leave
us tips as to what your Netflix theater
than yeah picking your options there
how's the game audio guys let me know if
it's if we can turn up a little bit more
writing
[Music]
dosing he looks like a twilight's tell
vampire more like oh you ruined it for
me it seemed like like a True Blood you
know you just have this like pale
complexion that day but the pill just
kind of adds contrast you know what I
mean like it does you can see like more
lines because there's a couple of other
mods oh yeah it's work Ahmad based off a
mod it's a tweak to a mod sort of to
really show off like it works better
with I think different lighting and
stuff there
there were additions mage trip to a base
mod to get it to look just like this
which looks good in my thing she is
oh wait got it there it is justice I
love blood and wine my favorite
expansion in all my gaming life Wow
I've heard okay that's the DLC for this
right that's supposed to be yes was
there more than one that there was to
you okay I think there's at least two
now does the switch version have like is
it it like a complete complete version
it's got to be right that's a good
question okay should be Oh sick flip all
right take off the blindfold everyone
should just be henry cavill like
everyone's face should just be modded
thank drowners or Stricker's we'll go
easy on you because you haven't
undergone the mutations knowing your
shoes i else trigger disobeying his
instructions i unwise I know and you
know that's no excuse there's also a mod
for cabals what your hair yeah there's
monster like his gear his sword is
apparel like all this sighs that's right
but I um but we I mean we just kind of
went with the face because that's that's
the that's the bread and butter this is
crazy it's working out so well
oh come on we'll practice with the
others down below witcher 3 would make a
good vr game maybe interesting maybe
maybe I should do this tutorial actually
that's fine it's coming up RG was it uh
possibly right yeah it was like just
Jasmine there you go run to the bottom
it says join Siri and a run along the
ramparts down the to the more courtyard
I'm the beater in this race go for it
someone says it doesn't look like Henry
why well if you mean Henry in The
Witcher maybe because we still gotta
like get the hair you know guard Barbour
he's got the scars oh he's got I thought
he had like two I forget the show does
he have does he have another one that's
not on here cuz he has a scar over his
eye I'm mixing my Witcher what little
Witcher knowledge I have my mixing it up
I'm mixing your tile lines already
this is not canon does the mod grow
facial hair over time like the default
gerald yeah
so here's the thing e in the game
because I believe you naturally will
grow a beard and facial hair over time
it will as well
and I think it's from what I was seeing
online I think when the facial hair does
come out it can be a little off with the
mod but there are ways to sort of amend
that okay
so keeping it clean might be best I
guess Oh possibly we'll see how it grows
if we've got we've got an hour and a
half on the stream we'll see if it does
anything hair day I have a lose better
the ponytail just gonna read that yeah I
think man this guy looks looks like he's
uh maybe a little too tain yeah hair
down cavil is probably a little Wilder
yeah it is it is like messy in the show
right
he barely keeps it up at all and it is
longer in the show faster snuggles
excellent name says witcher series on
Netflix is the best very good I
definitely need to finish it
mo he boss if I need to play this game I
never get the time to eat that's me dude
I literally
go ahead to cuz when we found out we
gonna do the stream it was cool cuz they
were like hey now you have time to play
I was like oh that's a massive that's a
tall order I do want to play but captain
goes you play The Witcher 3 in 2020 why
I'll tell you why we just downloaded the
mod from Nexus mods Henry Cavill space
yeah after all you seen the show you're
looking right at him and Boo Boo's got a
perfect counterpoint it says why not
right yeah it seems like it's a good
game to play in any year why do we play
games in general I'm guilty of replaying
a lot of games there's a funny meme
that's like playing new games are
playing old remasters like that's just
me so you did the reading why not admit
it right off because it's amazing duh
to have maximum effect I wish I could
pronounce your name Wow John says it
took me forever to bring myself to ever
play The Witcher 3 we're sort of in the
same boat don't know a little bit about
it never got really far the shows going
so far - but hopefully you're enjoying
what you're seeing especially with this
mod that we have dude is good right -
free training there we go this is up to
you a right to free training bro I'm
just gonna mess around with it yeah you
know what I'll just Rach add you see me
start flailing around you can just let
me know
give me some tips and pointers we're in
this we're in this henry cavill journey
together you'll get it huh yeah sorry I
just you're laughing it that way I got a
comment dude uh hunter Henry that
doesn't look like Superman looks more
like rocky that's a very specific rocky
yeah wonder why rocky for it looks like
Sly Stallone when he was in the early
nineties there yeah baby
or maybe was talking about a Drago oh oh
but I think that's a normal face drilled
right and this Evan yeah that looks like
normal face trouble me oh no he's back
okay
yeah yeah that was weird there were even
mods for girl to like get his
blacked-out eyes like if you really want
to go over a board we just want the face
Bob Jones in the chat what's up hey Bob
Jones Beck geek stuff says amazing game
love the way the show brought it back
from the dead kinda it's been off the
radar for a little bit there was some
DLC as we know and like just as it was
cooling down Netflix picked it back up
you've read the books let us know okay
JJ says it switches to the normal face
during the cutscenes I mean I think I
think it's the cutscenes that maybe
don't have a choice because it's back to
Henry here's yeah what I missed but that
like cinematic wasn't programmed for it
for that Valentin was like where did
Henry he's good we did maybe check and
answerable beeps questions of which were
books worth reading oh yeah I know Jake
we were trying to ask that - Jake read
the book yeah yeah Oh Jake if you don't
chat let us know dude he loves Witcher
he loves you Raja Fred he's really hyped
for cyberpunk as well oh yeah it was
funny I was about to say may be with
cyberpunk they're gonna do a Keanu
Reeves I was like wait a minute
yeah I forgot that whole intro sequence
was a dream
Akash says love this game heck yeah man
hope you like the Henry Cavill face mod
we got going on there like a stump hello
from Russia Henry yeah that knows the
street knows the eyes and it's all it's
so good you know that like kind of look
you get when you wear colored contacts
as well oh it doesn't quite look natural
right it like Charlotte they even like
hit that mistake or not it looks very
accurate yeah it's like a one-for-one
didn't overlook anything the books are
in youtube says Dumbledore Machat
interesting audio books are it right now
man do his follow our trail so Bob John
says I've read one of the books and it
was very good in the letter all right
how many are there good buddhu says they
should make a Serie Witcher game rule
well side you Hank 26 Michael G thrown
in some football chat to distract me it
seems a points for the Super Bowl
whoa calling it I don't I don't have a
horse in this race my readers got
eliminated
ooh that's private very private and
stuffed unicorn
yeah that's private you know we don't go
there we don't talk about this yeah the
music is good Thompson's eight books in
total oh wow okay mo Heep says can't
wait for cyberpunk 2077 who's fresh you
need to make the scar to one which
scarred cuz I see one over his eye
already but this might be the second
spar yeah yeah I was confusing my scars
earlier - I'm not sure in the series in
the beginning of the series he even has
the second scar yet well here we go
right so I know I can just like yeah you
can like blog use your little magic
defend role roles a good one yeah you
dodged there you go that's a dodge I was
looking for so I think jump and roll are
on the sink p5 and I wonder if that's
like rolling combat
okay also if you want to try the
controller I don't know how a more
comfortable you are fine there you go
[Music]
let me get a year in the chat are you
from New York my friend as far as I know
that's some New York slang you are
welcome here
let me get a year hi I'm from New
Zealand just kicking off the game also
hey great nice hopefully you're enjoying
our Henry Cavill mod here yeah I got it
if you haven't noticed his face it's
different hopefully uh hopeful as well
yes great way to do it
guys about how to get them up we have
Helene in our stream right yeah think we
should be in the description the Nexus
mod link right guys are at all
interested there's also there's the face
mod a full-blown hair mod sword mod and
the clothes that he wears on the show
all can be obtained yeah through the
next Zack jr. says you have it set on
easy difficulty problem do we yes
probably I think well because I mean
those are pretty entry-level you so it
imagines yeah they don't like they did
die pretty fast yeah I mean I'm not
gonna be doing this on like that Grand
Master or whatever no way dude we're
both rookies at this yeah if you just
joined us we we talked about getting
yeah we're we're both we're a little
green for both let's cool this is
probably our excuse to finally get into
this series because it's been in my
backlog but I have the same problem I
think I've told chat before like since
Witcher 1 & 2 over there like I want to
play them first so I can appreciate 3 to
the max and not just jump in there with
your 3 and that just makes my backlog
way more extensive so I call it excused
call it whatever I just haven't got
around to playing this so Jake actually
told me cuz I bought what you're wanting
to
and he said you know it's probably
better than just start with three just
wanted to can be a little rough around
the edges it's interesting I have heard
that starting with three oh there is no
this was ruining this little town
[Music]
I first the first time I saw it I
thought he was gonna die cuz there was
blood dripping from ledges neck but he
just bounces oh it's fine you don't you
don't have to fight them it's like
letting you know yeah there's a guy
underneath that cart who you say
fortunately but you don't have to fight
that thing just yet
see that's what I was asking maverick do
you have to play which are one and two
to play three are to get to play three
oh yeah Jake are our expert says maybe
not maybe even have to maybe just jump
into three but I do want to confirm with
them later cuz that's probably the route
I might have to end up going oh we got
destiny to steal a plan in the chat sail
boat in Mavericks running you guys hey
and sail boat says you don't have to but
you would appreciate the story more see
that's what I was afraid of I don't want
to lose little details with this coconut
head you saved his life and he's like
I've got a store or some money or
something like that
needed but uh you see something I think
he's like yeah you're fine yeah Oh 50
bucks 50 crowns
Milhouse says the mod looks like [ __ ]
okay well you know like Henry Cowell or
what you can keep that
told you there's an in here my tortured
soul but the sequel good god you've made
him pretty oh I love it yeah yeah he
doesn't look so yeah he still got the
voice but yeah he's got a handsome mug
there they're all in mo he bosses you
guys are awesome thank you my friend
Alyssa if you were talking about the
players in the games not us which is
well you appreciate you being here and
thanks for the kind words
thanks for joining us yeah that's right
JJ later later that coconut head guy
gives you a discount out of shop does he
yeah he sets up shop in town and he's
like I'll give you something for half
off does he give you a discount if you
don't ask him for money because I think
of my I've never seen that tree before
I've always maybe Zion says I think it
looks great appreciate it
let's go I mean it's not like our mod
but we want to have some fun and try it
out for sure
horseback though you can't see that
beautiful face it was the official name
of the guy who made this month because
there's a couple which one I think we
have the info
Stefan 3 372 I believe that's the Nexus
modest shadow Phonics shadow Fon ere we
go so shadow phonics I took my eyes off
the road sick my senses go go to Tavern
in Hawaii
so tell me how this little map I think
will tell you up there yeah oh yeah this
is a sidequest man here this is the look
at that face ya know what do you think
[ __ ] dimwit excuse me so if he I
think he offers you a side quest to
figure out who killed him if you say I'm
sorry actually I don't know if you say
don't install me it whilst offers don't
assault Henry Cavill mech if you can't
don't be demon there you go see it was
roasted some Weir's how dare you talk to
Henry Cavill like that oh hey welcome
back you were here with this yesterday
you say I would love a Henry Cavill face
mod for girls and Soul Calibur 6 not
cool yeah see this is a little side
quest first the tavern good luck good
building a my leg yeah see ya so Matt
said I gotta go back to the circles yeah
that's where the tavern is that's how
the main story progresses there are
millions of side remorseful what
Anderson Roach said him Roach yes either
that or you stole some randoms cows
he's a smart yeah he's like my boys
about to go and talk to this guy about
uh burning his own porch down when the
who killer bubbles asks where can you
get this mod this is quality my man just
check the link in the description we
have the Nexus mod posted up there you
can also get his hair some cool some
high effects the the clothes the sword
more mods are available today we just
have the face here we go you can see his
face here yeah there it is this scene is
replicated pretty well in the first
episode of the show like cuz you know
which er they go anywhere and there look
down on pretty much even though they
save lives
oh really yeah so he's gonna walk into
this bar and it's no bueno there makes
me think of like the COG and here's a
ward right Oh same deal yeah very
similar mmm no Mario not on console
unfortunately play on a PC
[Music]
get off me and waist area
if God
hey sailboats asking about you hey man
yeah I'm good
having a grand old Cavill time they were
just sad and wasted I was trying to
think of like why like mania died down a
little bit and here comes Henry Cavill
was like for just a moment I was like no
I'm just picking on him cuz you hate me
because I'm beautiful y'all you know no
need
mr. McDaniel says love this game been
playing it again since the Netflix
series came out it's gonna be well third
playthrough and plant into a 450 new
game plus this game supposed to be huge
so that's crazy you know like let me
know if you've ever hundred percent of
it I'm sure that yeah it's a big deal
what do you think of the DLC chat was
telling us earlier that uh some of it
was great outstanding stuffs
no that's an options yeah we're looking
to play we're looking for a woman yeah
we are
so that's lesson yellows I think that's
like the two forward the quest make sure
suggested maybe
smells them yeah there it is
gooseberries
we got a lot of PC fans in the chat PC
is a way to go it's fun for stuff like
this and of course the top quality group
of Netflix has been really good the last
couple days you guys have been there's
really funny yeah it's good having you
guys it's also nice to see returning
peeps our little extended family good to
have you here you know what that is in
real life he's a little teeny tiny like
mark on his nose fuzzy that they're not
really getting across I have to and we
have to get a real oh I think I see it I
was like I'm like the tip of the nose
like in the center there's like a little
line kind of like a cleft on his nose
it's very small they put in like the
shadows to make it work so see the map
so these circles are quests I'd imagine
okay so yeah it's just me asking the
patrons about lilac and gooseberries
yeah what's her name these guys are mean
but there's someone in the bar that
gives you some more Intel freak bald guy
in the back is basically a gun yeah yeah
there is a bald guy who helps you out
he's not mean like these guys oh there
you go if you use it that little spelt
that means you mind control them he's
like talk now talk look at that nerd
yeah he doesn't want he does exactly
exactly it's the best way to put it
which way did she go
don't know lots of tracks leading off
the main road could have gone anywhere
people the freaks taken bikers mind
nasiha says her toddler smuggler show
them berries right Ellie we got some
money Python fan
no white choices are furthermore details
for more information
and we're like more lore and background
on the quest maybe yeah it's nice
very good appreciate you helping us out
a cat was hissing at you the heebie cats
don't like witchers no the cat doesn't
like henry cavill means okay this guy I
think I'm in room 2 he's a little more
helpful but he's following the war he
likes to document war marquees these
aren't the droids you're looking for
that's right yep it's exactly what he
did in black and white I gotta use that
word sometime poppycock
that's a game he was playing now say
well card in the card game that's yeah I
can play well yeah that dude says the
earth shall revolve around the Sun by
the time you guys get to learn how to
play this game
the local people are there not on his
level this guy's the homie gopher oh
yeah is this the bald guy people were
saying in tears like a god I'm smells of
lilac and gooseberries dresses in black
and white see he's like you know what's
up I'm order you drink Hispanics yeah I
have a dream yeah
fine I'll have a drink the voice is good
it's not hard the mod yes but I'm think
now I'm thinking of the show and I'm
like Henry cavils does a good job of
replicating this exactly nice very good
nice Philly print system modeling for PC
I think so yeah you have to download the
manager right yeah it's the nexus mod
turn you up a little David actually
you're max don't mean termite down yeah
I got a scream into the mic no no that
mic I guess it's
you know yennefer water Starkiller says
face little more detail everyone's a
critic
it's good but yeah I mean it's gonna be
talking expressing yeah like a snapshot
of this though it's good it's fine yeah
for a mod I think it's good but I'm also
familiar with moths so maybe you've seen
some like yes I mean yeah it's also it's
not like we made the mod so yeah
everyone you're entitled to your binos
who you're talking about Oh mask
his name is gone throwed in for a reason
we don't have the first letter of his
name and you'll get it yeah then gob
what do you know tell me before you
appeared it never occurred to me that
might have been unified get to the point
yeah come on follow these guys where
these close-up shots are great yes and a
terse exchange with the garrison
commander erased off where - I'm not on
the siient ask at the garrison of
Nishant Thanks Yeah right I mean yes
cool
so scout yeah I'm appreciating these
conversations more because you get to
see the mod and you know that we're
talking about here right there are more
to the mods if you're just joining us
there is a apparel mod sword mod more
there's a hair mod although it's a this
hair is a little longer like it is on
the show the intro of the game where he
had it up and shaved on the sides looked
a little different
we're getting there but there is more
there's a link in the description of
this video there should be for the Nexus
mod if you're at all interested oh you
guys want some trouble oh yeah they do
want trouble
yo don't want your kind yeah
they played the sound effect they
spelled it out I love that three against
one either way there you go that little
magic trick there so either way you have
to fight them cuz they're onto you now
yeah this the horses are in peril
they're freaking out oh no okay is that
Rose Tattoo
let's see can you talk to him I think he
just oh he's he's losing it Oh looking
sad he needs a break okay so now we're
looking for it says a significant no
guardians about yennefer and then there
is a scout and an army leader you find
in within this town or maybe just
outside of this town that give you some
more answers anything on that map will
be helpful okay I see the saw the circle
way out here I don't know if that's part
of okay yeah that's where I got to go
down yeah cuz I wasn't sure it was just
gonna be like new people around here but
I'm sure I would
there are more side missions in town but
we can keep going with the story for
just that little I think it was like a
military fort mm area are we doing a
chats a bit laggy no no does it look
like e to you house I mean like I think
it's it like hitches a little bit I
don't know if that's because it's a lot
it's like well it looks fine to me
like when I move like up and down I can
kind of see you know uh oh okay so
little I do see it now when you move the
mouse with that right Richard Torah says
I wonder if Henry himself will play
through this game one more time because
of this mod that because I wish he were
here in the chat to say yay or nay yeah
someone tweet at any yeah Ragnarok says
I still been played witcher 3 you know
what that's okay we talked about yeah me
neither
we really haven't gone all the way
definitely not but you played more than
me it seems because you were telling me
about things oh yes I played a little I
played like the maybe like an hour in
and then last night to refresh I watched
that RiRi watched that hour
unlike the internet I'll play through
and it's good it made me want to play so
it's perfect we're playing today so
instead of show his face we will once we
yeah we're on horseback right now but
there'll be a cutscene any minute you
can ride the horse faster it says -
because this is his trotting well it's
cool we're in town anyway I think those
stairs are where you need to go if I
remember correctly for sure
[Music]
show his face we're getting there
friends for crying in the mud I look
like Henry Cavill yeah I'm Way too sexy
[Laughter]
see they're like hmm we can use this guy
to write the game very good
Clell says such a pretty game can even
be nice if you want to in it don't get
it custom
nor do the job go so this is where you
meet with some help yeah well I don't
know would you consider this before I
called it a fort just what do they call
it look at garrison this guy's like a
warlord
yeah but he's like a humble one is it
yeah he's like I'm a farmer like you man
it says it's a peasant farmer so we
speak how much can be real with me man
ham TV says its Leon from resume before
yes this is the Leon s Kennedy Monde
there he is he's like glowing dude can't
argue with your logic yeah there you go
geralt of rivia which nobody's of
Netflix remember it's what Chad said
[Music]
this military secret Oh Evan throw me
out
the guards so go ahead what's your price
there is a griphon ragnarok says I think
The Witcher is like talk talk talk and
more talks it's not much action he it'll
get there my friend yeah I think I think
there's some build up right yeah we are
opening this is the beginning part of my
you're gonna talk about people defining
quests I figure out more information is
you kind of gather it but there's like
opportunities to combat as well
we're just I'm actually kind of leaning
towards the talks a bit more more
because it means more close-ups that's
true that's very true as soon as we back
away and go on a horse the chats like
hey well let's see his face yeah the
moment that we're like in common space
we do - here is your art oh my God he's
hot and I'm playing that like squid
worst voice like squid that's where
we're at school iam fancy-son I'm
playing that in my head without a sure
he's all yoked I need to pretty good
look around well man show talking is the
best part of the game
[Music]
so we'll ragnaroks as I prefer
Assassin's Creed Odyssey I play backseat
but I've played a lot of assassins but I
think Ragnarok also was saying in the
chat that hasn't tried which are
creating tongue she get your hands on a
man's on everything stirred the basics
it's even on switch okay so this
herbalist will give you bait to catch
that the thing yeah oh god what they
call it
there's the herbalist buckthorn I think
but I don't know the name of like does
that bad bird thing what the hell is it
called help me out Jack you know what
I'm talking about Kai loot this or is it
it's fine he's gonna be like hold it
right there
Landry cavil some Elder Scrolls thing
you can't like oh they're at their Henry
kelp I just got yourself Jerry in the
chat yell welcome me welcome in exactly
Ragnarok everyone has opinions whatever
all good all good as long as you are
able to kind of enjoy what you like
that's all about it yeah and you're here
for a reason you know hopefully you just
enjoy hanging out with us enjoy and
enjoy ahead and right Havel himself
little caption well the Griffen Griffen
duh oh my god Griffin absolutely
[Music]
got Roach that's his name really bro ya
always think of cod Wow yeah I think I
think of God every time you're right so
okay we gotta go back there there's a
yeah you either one of those time to sit
the beat I do want to check one thing
real quick sure
just cuz like trying to just cuz like if
we do getting some combat all I haven't
really fully aware of its just hacking
slashing yeah I see
rolling is really good you can just
dodge roll or like there's a there's a
roll and there's a dodge like when we
just like Yakka I came onto the dodge to
my side mouse button it's just easier
for me sitting down now now on the chat
it's like hey this isn't tempt em some
holes oh oh oh that was a flip yeah
sorry bout we won with this Witcher mod
today but glad you enjoyed our Tim Tim
screams attempt on the spot those were
fun and today's the last day of that
part of that health oh yeah so yeah
which kind of is unfortunate so my poor
crystal is oh honey ball race no but I'm
um I'm very tempted to get the early
access you're very Tim Tim I'm a roach
is a she thinks unless your your your
for my chain here
that's funny so I'm already galloping
with a horse of I think chats that I
could go faster or know if there's
another button for it look it's like was
it like tap it or something
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Oh befriend Quinn hmm do my pinkies
gonna be yoked after this
oh it's shift maverick asks will you
guys be doing Monster Hunter ice-born
that's a great question I brought that
up today and our slack chat actually and
I talked to you our very own Erte you
can see what the deal was with ice-born
so guys in the office that are lost
throne or world pros are John Luke and
Ben you know I love them you guys know
him from community Fridays usually if
you tuned in and but John Luke is at CES
right now he's covering a lot of really
cool stuff he actually if you guys have
been paying attention to the CES news
there's that Alienware switch yeah it's
like a handheld console they revealed
he's got some really good stuff kind of
like some connections I think that we
might be yeah but he's got his hands
tied and he's in Vegas actually he'll be
coming home soon but right he guys we
cut out for him so you guys should
definitely tune in a GameSpot if you
guys are interested in any to CES here
and all that stuff to kind of see what
uh what we have in store but if they're
able to make it I think they would be
the best bet to stream the ice-born PC
port yeah if they're available it's a
kind of up in the air right now we're
hoping they'd be available or been
released
following the tracks if Oh
so Robert and we can't stream it though
we'll definitely try to get some
gameplay up right maybe some like 4k max
setting something along those something
yeah that's time we check in on our
YouTube channel not just our main one
but our GameSpot gameplay channel as
well right that's where he posts just
raw gameplay most of the time absolutely
Oh double tap shift and hold get to get
that run so chat same nice tip no
Dominic Smith says show me cavils face
behold right here you are
it's the reason we're here baby Soroush
says you signs hit Q on the keyboard I
will do that I don't know what you does
but we're about to find out those causes
the griffin killed I think those signs
were too little spells think yeah they
don't call it magic it's called like I
think it might be custom okay we'll see
you know we're both green here but I'm
fun I like that phrase green yeah it's
better than new
[Music]
lumped in your silver blades on blunt in
your silver plates yeah why not sure
who favorite moment from the show you
guys may have to answer that amongst
yourselves I've seen episode 1 I'm gonna
go back for the rest but I haven't
finished it all ok so science I think I
can use in combat so I'm gonna try to do
that next time I'm in a little sword
fight
all right let's go kill the wild dogs ah
bummer Justin Smith and chat he's not
digging the the texture he's not digging
the mod that's alright that's alright
cuz I'm diggin it yeah we're having a
great time yeah thanks for being here
anyway you know oh yeah
[Music]
oh that's right it's one of those
did you try Q is that we meant yeah one
of your signs is uh quite like kind of
paralyzing him for a little bit they
can't move but there's a few there's
like a we love those of those powers
right so you can swap between them yeah
one of them keeps he still one of them
sets up a shield through the few of them
sailboat says honestly the sword fight
in the in Episode one was awesome
yes that's cool that when I can relate
to because I've seen it yeah there is
look at that face he's so pressed he's
so upset I has feet hey man he's calling
us dog killers the game those were
wolves and they were trying to kill us
we love dogs here at games by least to
have canine Fridays you guys do it yeah
we do it's like this every couple yeah
if you guys follow me on Twitter I
retweet and I'm not just a lot of dogs
be sure to follow david on twitter
there's one just now it was like a
golden retriever that was just jumping
into his owners arms and then jumping
out running to his friend jeff it's like
oh he's like this is hey play catch with
your dog oh that's awesome it's like
that's my jam
although i'm a cat person
oh Ragnarok asks I'm supposed to follow
the hunter whoops-a-daisy
I was like oh hey I saved your boy
you're done with your TV show or a
Mandalorian which is a better move good
question
I feel like Mandalorian is more Scott
kind of America's here right now right
is it baby yeah both of them yeah
one of them's like you can't ignore the
other one maybe I mean you guys are here
all gamers you probably love The Witcher
it's much you know Bryce good questions
for Chad I should be asking me all that
too little scar there the whole like
details and stuff too good the cleft on
his chin and nose I'll be fine hope
you're right good huntin
[Music]
Peter says Witcher TV show it's better
for me personally
dragon rock comes back and says cool go
with mandalorian saturated with blood
yeah
Blue is like meaning let's ah that's
that one stuff yeah see yeah there is I
was where both are great chancing are
older
heavily armored
guardians probably whom you're on to
something they want to trail Witcher has
longer episodes that's a good point if
they're an hour long so it wins I like
them both yeah can we just let's just
have both not or that bird poop possibly
dude Henry Cavill dysentery note was
zapped into Witcher he's not that's the
thing he's like he never picks fights
with humans he knows when to pick his
battles whoo there he is it's Buckbeak
no least a week bad news it must be a
male
[Music]
deep cuts over the whole body not a drop
of blood on the decoy claws tab is a
quick access minutes didn't know
she asked me call him Henry your secret
we've been calling him a chat dubbed him
Geralt of Netflix Netflix CIA must be
about the same age we do shows didn't we
know what is the original well the hair
color because it was dyed white but
before that silver is always like this
grayish like it turned that way because
for a reason like because when s he
became a Witcher it like kind of been
started turned white but before
naturally though I don't know it's good
question for Chan oh I has feets as our
EP writ big versus a couple of weeks on
blue and the Chad says I think it's
black I think his hair might have been
black originally oh so tab is a quick
access for my signs yeah there they are
see someone in the chat who was it the
Aspire damage protective shield magic
show yeah yeah some of the chat mention
that but like someone's name so rush and
I'm probably butchering that has the
little symbol I think as their their
avatar on YouTube that's similar to my
cousin's name but I think it might be
pronounced differently yeah
oh there you go yeah
it's good to have you here look at that
hopefully we're not butchering your
experience of witcher 3 i like to think
of this as Clark Kent being an avid
cosplayer
that's good that's what uh earthly bump
says yeah probably better off out of my
way trying to embrace my inner dirty
arty uh yeah yeah more people in chat
Alba says I think it was black when he
was a kid
the hair yeah that makes sense
it's a really sharp contrast right yeah
yes I do trials to become a witch he's
kind of forced into being a Witcher as a
child
bad time those paints are all the way up
there where's his face here we go much
is the cutscene you're waiting for there
it is feel so good looking for buckhorn
buckthorn looking bright because he's
the herbalist so if it grows anywhere
around here where the channel is widest
but you do know that once out of the
water it'll stink worse than a week old
carcass we want to use it as bait need
the buckthorn for bait I was thinking a
few years ago we had troubled dramas
under the bridge whole village RS says
he should download a camera mod to zoom
in on his face even more I don't know
man I think we're good here
both scream honestly there needs to be a
mod where every character side
characters cut some characters they all
have him I'm in favor all those in favor
aye yes just a global face mod for every
character in Witcher 3 because us is
kind of looks like if girls were in his
late 20s or
he's like a nice young charming lad
which are with like a 40 year old
alright I has feet has to go thanks for
joining us friends see you next time
maybe next time oh wow she even said
what else for you I has feet else for
you baby next time yeah hey awesome
buckthorn on the riverbed using your
Witcher senses alright let's go all the
rivers right here
so this mod is a nexus mod available in
the link we have a link in the
description if you guys are at all
interested there are more mods including
his swords as apparel you can make it
all look like the show his hair you know
the hair is a little different in the
show it's a little more disheveled it's
all there but today we have we're
featuring the face
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Papa says the Henry Cavill model reminds
me of the ps2 era you know that's the
second time we've gotten down on Steam I
don't know what it is yeah
[Music]
getting some reactions to the face
[Music]
should
[Music]
yeah sorry roach should I get this game
you know what it's available everywhere
probably at a discounted price if you
like what you're seeing on stream maybe
you should check it out it's even on the
switch doctor go in the water
Oh is there maps yeah cuz that's it
grows alongside the river but this is
this little herb maybe maybe over there
where those poles are no don't lose
Roach so that's that yeah at all I think
I distracted with the other fighting
frag naraka nice cyber cyberpunk fans
new dude probably right I'm sure right
who were assaulted yeah oh yeah what
team wasn't you you mentioned it earlier
CD Projekt RED right yeah yeah some of
these must be or one of them must be got
a fossil oh yeah there we go
I don't like how the screen is warping
like yeah usually mean those bad dying
yeah there we go
hey they went away without
[Music]
come on cavil oh there it is and we can
all this breath for a long time
[Music]
I just need one oh cool
call Horace with X Oh God how do i how
do i surface hey oh now there's more
glowing over there did you pick some up
sorry I was looking I took it no you're
fine you're fine sweet I was just like
trying to grab as many as a kid but I
think I just needed one
sick sick sick sorrow says his hair
turned white as a side effect because he
he had undergone more mutations and
normal witches that's right he was even
put through more trials they gave him an
extra trial - like you need it I believe
you need to go - through three trials to
become a Witcher a Witcher and then they
gave him a fourth because he was so good
they're like just that badass yeah but
you know correct me if I'm wrong I'm new
to this
Eric Cartman in the chat Eric that is
are not Henry Cavill that is huh that's
totally honey go have you watch the show
let me know yeah let us know
[Music]
like how their text pops up like you can
listen into yeah let's see his face
coming up we I think we got a cutscene
coming up here for those of you have
just joined us pretty good this is what
it looks like in game but the real treat
is in these cutscenes yeah the cuts
these are they're great accepted
contract for the Gryphon got good news
and bad news
good news first paradox acres hello T so
those were uniform hey hey of going-ons
that we have to kill the Griffon foreign
what else getting one for two witches go
on tell me what you think's are joining
us Griffin's abandoned its lair got a
make up is it a trap
going got some Buckhorn already either
way yeah yeah the woods down killed its
mate
smashed their eggs thought they'd fixed
things ah paradox II it's kind of sad
you're not streaming Tim Tim you know
what maybe when it comes out in the
final bill will be back to play it some
more even the early access to be honest
that's right that comes out later this
month I think that'd be pretty cool yeah
I appreciate you tuning in for the past
few days we're streaming Tim Tim or some
fun city boy rotting meat you're pissed
standard smells of the country sorry Oh
interesting number Tredegar having that
zoo girl in the trashy abhinash sex I
bought what your three but as soon as I
press the controller the feedback put me
off Assassin's Creed is better in that
respect in my opinion fine with
controlling so yeah interesting yeah cuz
I actually I I fell off on Assassin's
Creed I'm ready
around unity - hmm which had its own set
of problems but after all the patches
already the feedback from that for me
and on controller was fuse and right in
like it everything felt like bomber
reporters exceptional delayed oh the
earlier I loved mark I couldn't stand
that I think black clock might still be
my favorite
as for the input right now I mean I'm
playing on mouse and keyboard smoldering
yeah you're on fire I'm just I'm just
that hot you're Henry Cavill baby yeah
this is just just how he lives life that
was good uh where's roach road Oh press
X I think to call them Oh unless that is
roach that is Roach - but that's that's
good to know
okay cool thank you chapter that one
lazier Brom says this mod actually makes
me want to buy the game go for it go for
it on PC check it out the only place to
get it there's a little mod there's a
lot of a lot more mods - right yeah we
if you are interested there's this face
mod there's a hair mod closed sword mod
you can just match it to make it look
like a Henry Cavill on the show like all
the way to the nines
what's your 3 on ps4 feels clunky oh man
that sucks that's how I would play it I
think you know what I'm yeah am i
hearing that doesn't make me want to buy
it on the switch because I had some
interest in doing that
cuz I can take it anywhere but yeah so I
wonder if they buffed out all that out I
think Jake actually reviewed which are
three on the switch even though you know
we're on the video team but he just know
so much about it yeah that means given
the opportunity to review the switch
port or waves and he you know she loved
it but I think that was one of his
thing's was like if you are going to
enjoy Witcher so I mean PC is just kind
of the better to do it to be honest yeah
like to really bask in the scope and the
grand scale of everybody makes sense
it's a graphically demanding game there
is exactly it is we have to
is wait come on we can cower in the
shade of those birches
so tell me once we find yennefer what
will you do
damn you Salazar in the chance of but
this is a deeper game then God of War oh
you guys are having this conversation
huh very different experience he says no
guards crossed the pond tar in the east
puts them and their weeks march from
Cara Morgan if they reach the valley
before snows can cover the passes we
need to cover our tracks
reading Henry paddy looking off into the
guys yeah pretty dreamy gotta say bring
a guest
oh that is that bait like a fake I think
I think the bait is in there okay cuz
the scent of that plant we could that's
it it's time
Oh David you ready for this uh I'm gonna
need your support emotional support yes
David David in the chatting spamming my
[Music]
which with a crossbow break my tradition
Chris as a hope of what you're for lets
us create our own witchers I'd be cool
took the bait
almost right well you got help you got
help how do I use the crossbow though I
like that entity you equip the crossbow
there Eddie the nice dodge roll that was
sweet
[Music]
there we go very cool oh-ho nice you got
this Henry Cavill this is like how the
show starts you're not fighting a
Griffon like this this is almost like a
blood-borne you just have to like hug
the waves and master you're dodging
you're good yeah
there he goes like what about me no
you're doing good he's got half help yes
we are playing on mpz on PC clerk says
his easy guys all right see all right
you got the aidid good yeah I'm me some
bread nice a little break in the middle
you got a chaser
I think he'll dive-bomb back because
that's not cool
unless you do with them
the only mission objectives still says
kill the Griffon oh he did he landed
over there if you're right do anything I
move let's go let's go let's go
be careful wild horses this musics labs
good it's good
what difficulty is this I think we're
probably like we're sorry yeah it's
gotta be no he's a grandmaster guys yeah
new game+ yet new gameplay now we didn't
uh we started it just like yeah every
every animal be like expert double gold
Nuzlocke
can't touch this middle mouse button
equals crossbone okay maybe I can just
what he minded now well he did yeah
there we go
appreciate that though set him on fire
Dave oh he's up he'll do not hit Henry
Cavill like this watch the face watch
the face show your face we're getting to
the after this Gryphon fight will
probably be a cutscene you'll see Henry
Cavill very soon look at that but sick
we got him we got him gggg shoot him
down yeah we missed the crossbow but
yeah we did he came dive-bombing
there's your face chat yeah probably
what bro excuse me I'm Henry Cavill
[Music]
that's okay I'm not saying he's talking
to us not yeah that's a girl
Lorenzo's saying see what they did with
The Witcher 3 I'm really tempted by
cyberpunk as soon as it comes out there
you go that's good man sounds like a lot
of us here in the office I think I think
cyberpunks the most one of the most
anticipated games of this year by far
oh yeah I mean last of us too as well oh
god I can any destiny expansion for me
but yeah
so ragnarok with the hot takes death
training is the worst game of 2019 oh my
goodness but I did you know some people
had it was very polarizing but yeah we
we had lockers for it which I'm sorry I
had to give you some of my and my
footage I knows I was like running
around a lot and getting always checking
my menu every leg you know what against
chapter three even if he hadn't done
that chapter three is the longest
chapter in any form of the media ever so
it would have been long no matter what
the seas are cool though they are cool I
think that acting was really really good
this looks like a deep fake oh that's my
I mean it pretty much is mod is like OGG
fake yeah right it's like it's like the
face the face also just paste it on yeah
movement eyebrows moving no and collect
your reward from enough Guardians on my
way we cleaned up we saved your town
yeah we can save man we killed your you
drop and give me 20 Z not again
whoo Chris in the chat I know the worst
game but this one's hurtin my feelings
yeah that's very much but you know what
I get your opinion he says worst game
2019 should we call of Colin paste copy
I like it as clever it's clever but I
have to disagree with that because
modern warfare was actually it did a lot
of things with like the campaign it kind
of brought me back dude although you
know it did get rightfully criticized
for that wreck coming of the highway of
death yeah that was a yeah it was a it
was a little controversial campaign is
good by others yeah I like the campaign
though yeah it's good it was tense man
you know yeah and I'm a sucker for like
most call of duties especially throwing
Modern Warfare that's where I'm at so I
love this year's entry it was it was a
tense game maybe not as tense as a Henry
Cavill space right no that's a great
shot back on topic look at that face
look at that mug someone who chatted
earlier was like I wonder if Henry
Cavill would want to play this now that
this mod is on yes that'd be fun you
should live stream with us dude Henry
Cavill on live stream make it happen
yeah yeah hope we are not done it's
yours
thank you that's what we're working for
the gold man oh yeah witcher's duty it
ain't free turn down the coin whoa do
you got me tell him to have my money use
what you sense to zoom in on his face oh
nice yeah there you go
there it is you know what it looks good
but I think it looks better in these
cutscenes they were like made for
cutsies are 100% the best like whoa you
jumped into a fight here those guys
though whoa oh
why they start beating you up and this
day I have no idea but I got a GGC have
you been oh you oh my G your only
mission is to prepare to leave Oh
oh my god the whole full fort I saw you
try to throw that up didn't work where's
Ben Samir hello oh don't let him throw
some matches know what that was our
first death of this whole game yeah
you're doing great
I don't know the town went loco they
went cuckoo for cocoa puffs what's going
on oh I stole okay I we were worried
about that what I was saying I was like
an alliance game and I accidentally
oh hey look Chad is calling us a thief
no well we paid our price it was never
intentional Chad I like how they kill
you and now everyone's just like over it
chillin by the campfire we got some FS
thank you very much yeah
locked what the hell yeah oh this one
here there we go
God oh boy what's his name vesemir is on
the other side of the man other your
pets gotta go yeah
dude one sword swept and half my I am I
thought this was easy mode thief that's
why ever be nope we know we're a thief
that's what happened we didn't know that
oh we got a match to the check it's okay
respect you know that's what that means
respect for the loss here tender
campaign respect with the silvery moon
blue drops an L in the chat l question
why yeah a little-little L there did I
just I just use that on my voice the
right way I know we love you wrote that
the Griffins head sick on your side
there we're sorry oh yeah yeah no I've
been it's like it's like a little trophy
right yeah okay I'm just going back to
back to town
nooooo - c'mon says what do you think
the cyberpunk multiplayer is gonna be
like like GTA online guess is as good as
mine to be honest yeah we're all like we
all want to know yeah you're probably
gonna see more of the game I would
assume maybe around e3 right it's gonna
be a lot of cool stuff we're not on III
vesemir is up north north east of the
camp you're going the right way that's
where that dot is I believe but Thank
You Chad for helping us out I want to
call you I mean that's your name the
last part of your name there so Roush I
knew but correct me if I'm wrong like
inés a German word actually mmm I think
it means like a or one but I you got me
actually the soundtrack is dope says
paradox acres yeah soundtrack was cool
there was um we were fighting the
Griffin I was like really taken it will
pump up with the music something wrong
look around trouble there it is there's
the there's the face can you imagine
playing that game and oh I don't
remember what that ain't yeah where were
you I don't know it was five finger
something they call it house jeez help
us out chats there was like find another
one will you play with the knife in
between all of your fingers oh whoa wait
five finger I won't sit five finger
death punch well that's a metal band
oh no if I figure something though your
watch this I'll look it up watch this
google breath yep oh yeah yeah sorry
Clell actually the game I think it does
release before you three I think it
comes out like this May so
definitely right good catch no way man
Google has no idea what they have I'm
talking about someone's gonna leave
that's i'm hype for cyberpunk in the
chat heck yeah
who's hype for the PS 5 oh yeah
I'm their day ones is right
yes Mikasa this game and the show are
based off a book series we talked about
that right eight books I believe in the
serious macsyna math just actually max
oh my God thank you that yeah if I
figure fillet that's it oh my god max oh
[ __ ] we're missing out oh my god that's
the whole head fillet right there
oh you shove you shove the home there
should be a full-blown mod a Superman
mod for this all right he's like you're
right all right yeah this guy's been a
punk oh great yeah you want sort you
want to bring clubs to a sword fight all
right
he hates to fight humans he never you
know that's part of the thing it's like
we even said it into the show he's like
boy why don't someone was like you don't
pick on you don't fight humans like if
they're me I mean he was like no because
then I am what they say I am a monster a
monster
see you Ragnarok he's heading now ladder
man thanks for joining us yeah
it's alright time to choose we're trying
to help man see that's exactly what
happens every time I bought says we guys
stream the full game close to 2 a.m. in
my place considering I think the pool
games only like 60 hours yeah I looked
up a down play yesterday
that's 17 hours at least and that's
probably likes like massed yeah no no
we're actually probably gonna close it
off in about 12 to 15 minutes or so but
uh we just wanted to show what Henry
Cavill looks like as The Witcher yeah
which iPod this live stream will be
available later and also will probably
use this gameplay for a GameSpot
gameplay video absolutely absolutely
finally watch it be some dude back in
who's Barry yes on says you did not have
to kill that not [ __ ] really hey man
they were picking on runaway that lady
was picking on the other lady yeah let's
all be friends yeah Chris hospira SOG
yes we'll all be friends
[Music]
Henry you look more beautiful in the
normal Nick Ren MC Ren says The Witcher
3 is longer than 17 hours yeah that was
that was just one example yeah that was
like a speed rush yeah look at that 70
hours long that's like almost persona 5
territory oh my god there's not a lot to
do and DLC it's the rush where you go in
the editor the last six but she's like
touch my very strong square job right
how can you resist
yennefer yep the whole chat is excited
isn't an occurrence probably got
yennefer hyped everyone yeah she was
like a fan savers
[Music]
last time we saw each other in order to
kill me their destinies are like
intertwined I think they made it so by
making some sort of wish I forget what
the lore is oh really yeah what'd you
say I did that's cool I know chat could
tell us that's really what they're like
meant to be forever I suppose it came
out
guess I'm willing to hear him out
because it's you yeah yeah about fantasy
games in like lore or some like reading
the weight of these it's crazy coming up
with like your own universe right of the
ground up milf Guardian scratch yeah
it's crazy it's like inspired by other
things but you still got to do a lot of
leg work too soon you'll be so creative
right for sure you might have like
Nordic influence or something yeah very
creative oh yeah there she is friends we
found her we got folks saying how many
hours have logged in the game it seems
like there's a lot of really hardcore
which advances yeah maybe you tell us we
got some big fans here in the chat MC
Ren welcome back home you two not played
this game before this my personal
greatest game ever made well I'm glad
that you loved it
you caught us red-handed bro yeah we're
talking the chat earlier when we started
we are pretty green on this game
Richie's played a little bit more than I
have but I think we're reaching on
territory maybe that yeah it's like
pretty early yeah I was I didn't get too
far past this in fact like it was like
it was around here we're just like it
for me right just the beginning but it
is we're having a good time and this
whole henry cavill max mask mod is great
the mod is available in the description
of this video by the way
why didn't you guys use a yennefer mod
as well do it I don't even know if there
is one we were saying let's get a whole
global henry cavill mod where everyone
is henry cavill but that's not a
possibility you can get swords the
clothes the hair to make it look just
like the witcher on netflix if you want
that's all available but like I've been
saying today we only got the face yeah
please don't mod Jennifer as well that's
so chad is saying hello welcome
[Music]
300 hours but I just started playing the
whole the trilogy Wow element us thanks
for sharing
ah hi told you man we don't have a
uniform on we won't be cool but the only
one that we had access to was the Henry
Cavill one that would be cool though I'm
sure you know what after this it's
probably in the works that just says
you're headed to work have a great day
to you as well ma'am
you too thanks for joining us in pure
extreme awesome Maudie guys just sold me
a PC copy hey cool
although we got mentioned before so this
is shadow phonics is mod correct that
you can get with the Nexus mod like The
Witcher 3 mod builder it's kind of like
a little client you're gonna download it
and then you rub the game from there
yeah if you've modded before you should
be okay
so you just skip that yeah henry cavill
well actually just his feet in the tub
right yeah he's got a place areas that's
Superman right there ah chat is saying
there is a yennefer mod already
I wonder if that's cool just match her
like some like the show with my beard
he's got a little bit of a scruff he's
got some scruff coming right we're going
to talk about that yeah like it was
gonna happen on the I wonder I wonder if
it's like maybe check and tell us in
this scene if a.g here along has like a
longer beard yeah yes maybe it locks it
so that he only has that little five
o'clock shadow like in the show i
mantises Nexus mods correct yes there's
a link below in our video where you can
go to Nexus mods download the client oh
yes but this version of Henry Cavill
that we have is shadow phonics is
because there's a bunch of other
different types of Henry Cavill mods as
well but we kind of like this one yeah
the one we use should be in the
description how it goes hey is this the
barbers because these
yes general the gentlemen will be yeah
it sounds like he had a really gross Bo
whoa Superman the Silver Surfer what is
this I hope it I hope it comes back he's
supposed to have a long beard here by
this point do you have a second chance
to go good that's our thumbnail baby
that's so funny I kind of hope it
doesn't River back to Henry Cavill now
we're questioning you dude we're not
even sure I love it cuz all the way to
his neck
it looks terrifying Marvel super sick oh
my god well he doesn't have the best
hygiene well it seems so I don't think
metal has hygiene oh my goodness so a
haircut trips it up I can't believe it
we had a great run this is actually a
pretty good time for it to like do that
because we have about four minutes left
I kinda miss it already
yeah he was shiny oh my goodness
that's very good this true form came out
yeah hey there's my boy though he's back
Hugh it's good to see him look at that
that's what we're here for
[Laughter]
what type of alternative lifestyles girl
living the texture was fully removed you
know it is I like that
third one although the first thing the
third one looks similar I think it's the
design first one's got oh this one's a
little more don't go dude he's ripped
yeah look at those back muscles yeah
they show you that as soon as he gets
out of the tub when the game starts he's
like oh let me just get out of here
[Laughter]
he's literally flexing on us right now
we have nothing
Mikasa yeah well that was a trip yeah
what the but do you have to talk to him
to get dressed
I just grabbed all the clothes there we
go
lead him ah I didn't like I didn't
expect it maybe I have to go to like a
closet or something yeah just walk out
like this man
where's roach it's time to go that's
true we can loot it says get dress and
talk to the moon we
maybe I'm missing open your inventory
thank you so nice having you here I need
on Chatham to call you honey
[Music]
there you go just keep the towel maybe
some boots oh my god impossible wonder
if they let you leave
some kicks there you go cool it worked
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah ready ready for battle let's don't
mind my towel I don't see anything wrong
but Henry's outfit ah
they really do stop you can't have any
fun huh
beautiful that's gonna be a great place
to call it let's see what he has to say
and then yeah it's time for us to end
the stream today yeah well we'll end on
after this dialogue just give one last
good look at Henry Cavill feast your
eyes yeah there is enjoy a studded
doublet disorder back
yeah he's not repping the right clothes
and he doesn't like it it's like yes
actually you're Henry Cavill no makeup
compliers light enough I'm pale AF right
now yeah I don't know how to bow man I'm
not a poor I know how I like the scar
they have right here his character says
it's a white kilt not a towel you can
flip it up really it looked like a towel
right after the bath but we couldn't
leave with it even if we wanted to
scientists you can keep it sell through
the whole game with an equip switch
that's funny oh that's funny yeah what
mod is enough I guess huh we're really
getting a bowel tutorial hours all right
folks this is upset oh my god Oh What
did he say
I totally forgot I forgot the order to
what wasn't I was talking over it oh my
goodness
[Music]
200 lashes good lord
good luck getting through my enormous
back muscles yeah that's right
won't last one hurt at all yeah exactly
I was it again
I don't know you know what it was like
just it was it was one of these close my
eyes oh shoot he straight up like he dad
he like downward dabbed Oh work perfect
all right that's how you just is how you
greet royalty yeah all right everybody
we're gonna call it there thanks for
tuning in if you want if you are
interested in this mod it is the Nexus
mod that is available in the chat
description in the description box of
this video turn it down a little bit but
thanks for tuning in guys we will be
back tomorrow we're streaming we stream
every weekday from our starting at 11
a.m. Pacific Standard Time 12:30 so tune
in we'll be back tomorrow thanks again
for tuning in
and uh definitely actually you know make
sure you like and subscribe man we're
gonna be here all the time we'd love to
have you guys with us true definitely
check out our YouTube channels we got
the GameSpot gameplay channel that
Richie and I work on you have to be
posting a lot of these breakouts
including it's probably including this
yeah so if you guys are interested in
seeing any game play definitely check us
out and yeah you know have a good one
you guys nice to see your um take care
of you guys bye bye